nous ont rejoints sur le plateau alors
on à nicolas dupont aignan président de
debout la france un mouvement politique
je suis plutôt à droite de la droite
vous reprochez notamment une
instrumentalisation du gouvernement des
scènes de violences de samedi sur les
champs-elysées et de vouloir
décrédibiliser mouvement des gilet jaune
je pense qu'elle a beaucoup qui sont pas
d'accord avec vous julien bayou est avec
nous est le porte parole d'europe
écologie les verts est peut-être
prochain maire de paris en tout cas vous
avez annoncé votre candidature pour 2020
ce week-end vous étiez à paris d'abord
avec les gilet jaune puis puis lama puis
à la marche contre les violences
sexistes du côté de l'opéra garnier et
ça c'était très important qu'on veut on
dire avant il y avait plus de monde
il y avait énormément plus de monde et
moins de médias malheureuse alors oui
c'est vrai exactement ça c'est fait
pacifique ouais et je suis d'accord avec
toi en finir avec les violences faites
aux femmes faut se donner les moyens
exactement on va on va revenir de ceux
ci il ya jean que ce boulot qui étaient
avec nous et l'agent vous êtes
journaliste pour ses news
et vous est ce week-end mobilisés pour
la manifestation on a maxime maxime
voilà qui me lâche pas a maintenant
qu'est gilet jaune et qui vient d'être
désigné comme l'un des huit porte parole
du mouvement
gilet jaune et on à benoît qu'eads avait
nous merci besoin qu'on voit pour la
première fois et gilet jaune et il n'est
pas satisfait de l'organisation des
gilet jaune alors on vous l'a dit donc
10 heures on a vu les gilet jaune
envahissent les champs elysées la
question que vous à poser est ce que les
événements de samedi ont décrédibilisé
le mouvement ou pas vous donnerez votre
avis ici
10h35 les forces de l'ordre font usage
de gaz lacrymogènes pour faire évacuer
les manifestants
regardez trouve au niveau du rond-point
des champs-elysées au croisement avec
l'avenue montaigne et on vient de le
voir l' usage de gaz lacrymogènes
saint-amand il était difficile de le
savoir est un mouvement de foule
des gilets jaunes ont commencé à courir
et à remonter vers la place de l'étoile
là ça s'est calmé les on commence à
remonter à remonter calmement il marche
certains appellent les autres
manifestants à remonter pour l'instant
tout s'est calmé
alors un maxime maxi vous êtes invaincus
vous êtes un des représentants des gilet
jaune
pourquoi avoir été sur les
champs-elysées alors qu'on vous a dit
d'aller sur le champ de mars
dites nous ce que vous savez que c'est
interdit on l'a on en avait parlé sur
ballons ce ton post juste la veille et
vous saviez que ça allait poser les
problèmes pourquoi vous l'aï fait parce
que le champ de mars
c'est une solution et on savait très
bien qu'on allait être parqués sur cette
place oui on va avoir la possibilité
d'aller là où on voulait c'est-à-dire
devant les champs-elysées pour être
reçus
c'est ce qui était prévu c'est ce qui
avait été demandé officiellement à ce
qu'une délégation soit reçue et ils ont
complètement fermée cette place alors
pour éviter que les gens ici
oui mais alors vous avez vu parce que
vous avez dit pas les aide pas de ballet
sur les champs elysées vous avez vu que
le voilà ça a dégénéré
pourquoi ça a dégénéré qu'est ce qui a
déclenché islah qu'est ce qui a
déclenché le voilà pour que ça dégénère
comme ça parce que je sais que vous vous
n'êtes pas que d'accord benoît avec la
leyre l'organisation qui s'est passé
samedi
comment s'est passé samedi déjà
premièrement moi je condamne toutes les
violences
faut savoir que c'est un mouvement
pacifique à la base oui mais oui j'ai là
on fait parler que de ça on parle que
des violences mais faut pas oublier que
dans toute la france il ya 2000 poindra
sans dire hey you say pacifique lectorat
par suri donc c'est pas méchant
alors bien sûr 22 la tension monte début
des affrontements entre les manifestants
et la police et les journalistes comment
même commence même à parler des casseurs
qui sont arrivés regarde alors connus
qui sont sa prestation une centaine de
membres du bureau à droite il y a
plusieurs individus qui sont vraiment au
contact avec les forces de l'ordre ils
ont établi une grande barry can avec
tout le mobilier urbain qu'ils ont pu
trouver ils ont aussi à desceller des
pavés de ses champs elysées pour
affronter les forces de l'autre quand on
voit bien différent d'un côté la grande
majorité des gilet jaune sont là pour
porter des revendications façon
pacifique
et puis on voit aussi une petite
minorité de capteurs demande de
mouvements radicaux qui sont là n'ont
pas pour soutenir les gilets jaunes mais
pour abîmer notre démocratie
alors jean chamoulaud justement vous
êtes journaliste pour ses news vous
comment vous avez vécu les choses
c'était assez intense est assez
troublant ce que tout s'est très bien
passé au début de la journée on a vu les
gilet jaune arrivé au compte gouttes en
haut des champs-elysées la place de
l'étoile très pacifiquement dans le
calme j'ai envie de dire et puis c'est
parti un
d'un coup en fait quand les jeunes ont
voulu descendre vers parti à parti mais
de qui j'étais pas si vous voulez
j'étais pas en première ligne si vous
voulez avec gilet jaune alors dit tout
ce qui s'est passé mackenzie s'est passé
c'est qu'il y avait des gens assis par
terre les mains levées et que les crs
ont commencé à gaz et pour faire reculer
les gens et moi je voudrais rajouter que
les policiers et les crs soutiennent le
mouvement et les gendarmes
oui on le sait me rends donc voila
c'était non mais et donc donc voilà
est-ce que parce que il y avait il y
avait des règles aussi il avait dit
palais sur les champs est-ce que c'est
pas le fait que vous ayez voilà
transgresser les règles qui a fait que
ça ait dégénéré
adacore non mais dites nous si on
transgresse une règle ça veut dire qu'on
est en droit de se faire taper sur la da
rocha sur alors on est assis pacifique
non mais surtout fars mais je pose la
question voudrait dire une chose moi
dans la journée j'ai énormément de
personnes qui me suivent sur les réseaux
sociaux qui m'ont dit faut être
pacifique et vérifier le pacifisme c'est
un peu compliqué quand on est si près
mais très bien soyons pas s'y fier toute
la journée
j'étais visage découvert sans gants sans
casque sans rien du tout pour montrer
que j'étais pas un black bloc je ne sais
pas quoi et de façon pacifique et je me
suis pris 30 coup de gazeuse dans la
tronche et je me suis fait thierry une
grenade dans le dos alors que je mets
fera en sorte qu'elle alors juste de crs
puisse passer en enlevant des gens qui
voulaient bloquer le camion mais on va
devoir 1 par la brillance c'est sûr
qu'en mai juste moi ce que je voudrais
vous dire juste moi je me fais l'avocat
du diable bien entendu je vous pose des
questions comme les téléspectateurs
peuvent se les poser comment ils peuvent
faire la distinction
les forces de l'ordre sur le terrain de
d'un gilet jaune comme on dit parce
qu'en ce moment on parle de bons gilet
jaune et de mauvais gilet jaune devrait
l'atteindre chômeurs jeunes et de kasr
al aqsa exactement où j'ai rejoint les
deux casseurs mais ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on est beau mais le ciel était qu'au
niveau journalistique j'ai apprécié le
fait que les journalistes ce jour là ont
bien distinguer âgées les jeunes restera
sur oui ou non
alors oui je sais pas si vous avez vu je
sais pas si vous avez vu aussi bon pour
vous dire vous avez vu le tweet chef
d'état qui parle de casseurs il parle
pas de gilet jaune mais qui parle même
de guerre voilà weebe parle de casseurs
il ne parle pas de gilet jaune dans son
tweet alors vous les affrontements donc
continuer puisque je voulais dire à
partir de 11h 22 donc ça continue à
12h16 ya christophe castaner le ministre
de l'intérieur qui prend la parole et il
évoque le bilan à la mi journée de la
mobilisation il tacle aussi marine le
pen
ce que nous constatons c'est un fort
affaiblissement de la mobilisation au
niveau national il y avait à 11h23 mille
personnes qui étaient mobilisés dans
différents lieux au niveau national
contre 124 mille à la même heure la
semaine dernière les séditieux ont
répondu à l'appel notamment de marine le
pen et veulent s'en prendre aux
institutions j'appelle les responsables
politiques de ce pays à les dénoncer
plutôt qu à les alimenter alors là je
voudrais vraiment on fasse pas devant là
on va pas rentrer dans un débat
politique jeu juste savoir la question
elle est simple est-ce que cette journée
du 24 novembre
elle a décrédibilisé mouvement ou est-ce
qu'elle l'a renforcée voyez que marine
le pen ensuite a tweeté et sinon après
une semaine de mobilisation des gilet
jaune
le gouvernement at il quelque chose à
leur dire pour répondre à leurs
souffrances et à leur angoisse de
l'avenir
alors julien julien bayou vous êtes
porte parole d'europe écologie qu'est ce
que vous dites là j'en ai déjà personne
va surfer sur les violences parce que
marini enfin j'entends si vous êtes fait
taper dessus
ça y est nous ça nous arrive
malheureusement beaucoup les écolos
j'imagine les mobilisations pacifiques
et je sais à quel point ça peut être
frustrant de voir la manifestation des
tournées pourri par des casseurs qui qui
qui décrédibilise - le mouvement mais si
vous répondez
c'est là que vous perdez tout est lié et
j'allais devenir vous l'avez obtenu je
suis d'accord la violence ce qui
l'attendait à tourner et c'est très
important c'est que l'âme la difficulté
c'est qu'on ne sait pas qui porte la
parole c'est à dire que vous êtes en 2g
les jaunes y en a un qui vit on est
rigoureusement pacifique et donc oui
j'ai plutôt envie même si je soutiens
pas vos mots d'ordre de d'entendre la
colère qui s'exprime le ressentiment et
dans ce cas là je dis au gouvernement
mais soyez pas fermé écouter recevait
une délégation exact mais des asa partir
du moment où vous laisser la violence
répondre les mâles ouvrir ça va arrêter
cette violence quand c'est les crs qui
la déclenche et je vous explique bien me
dire c'était oublier charge mais ça
s'appelle la dgi reculé à jury bien ça
s'appelle la résistance passerait
d'accord on peut vous faire un musée
facile mais est ce que vous y étiez
samedi vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
vous y est magnifique et il est avec
elle je vous demande si vous êtes fait
ce qu'il était il était sûr c'était très
important d'être sur la manifestation
bien sur des femmes qui étaient prêts à
boire
alors juste maxime maxime comment vous
oui juste nous on voit là on en entend
vos revendications mais comment comme je
vous ai dit comment voulez que les
forces de l'ordre fasse la distinction
entre des casseurs et
gilet jaune pacifiste d'objets vous leur
expliquez m'a dit nous dans les gens
sont en première ligne pacifiste et que
les crs chargent
qu'est-ce que ça déclenche non mais il
charge pour vous faire reculer parce
qu'il voulait pas que vous alliez
s'était cassé les jambes je peux débat
de seconde par lesdits parce que ça fait
une semaine qu'il ya des manifestations
partout et là on réduit le débat aux
violences de samedi mais parce que
justement je vous dis ça non mais benoît
benoît et maxime pourquoi je vous dis ça
et pourquoi je vous parle que de ça
parce que on pense
vous avez beaucoup sollicité des médias
ces derniers temps
et forcément les médias ils vont pas
montré des manifestations qui se passe
bien ils vont de combien de personnes
non mais non mais maxime juste on est
obligé de passer ça parce que le grand
public qu'est ce qu'il a vu samedi et
dimanche toute la journée en boucle la
boucle
moi j'étais pas là j'étais en tournage à
un ami je recevais des sms c'est la
folie tu te rends pas compte
nicolas dupont aignan oui et on était
heureux sans c'est qu'on a assisté à une
immense mise en scène une manipulation
mais comme jamais c'était assez
insupportable je vous le dis comme je le
ressens un supporter a alors mais ça ce
que je vais vous dire vous attends moi
j'étais non non attendez en scène si je
peux oui une mise en scène olivier jean
qui tablaient sur ouï dire des faits qui
tapait sur des finitions
tu peux finir mal on s'excite moi je
vais vous dire une chose reste à côté de
nous c'est que d'abord je lui disais
juste banalisée comme ça les violences
finition du point sony soit mais je peux
quand même dire à y finir ma phrase
william j peut-être c'est d'abord champs
elysées c'est curieux la place de la
concorde était fermé donc ça veut dire
que monsieur kastner quand il veut
fermer un endroit il le faire elle n'a
jamais atteinte horizon manifestations
il ya eu 15 bien entendu non mais vous
pouvez pas dire lâche avis extravagants
je vous dis non
laissez moi finir monsieur dupont aignan
le gouvernement vous auriez télé
réalité10 des chevaux de cinq mois les
jalousies finish et jeudi jeudi il a
réussi à fermer la place de la concorde
et donc essayé voulait fermer là est-ce
qu'on peut écouter additionner chez si
on voulait fermer les champs elysées
pouvait le faire il a créé une
souricière il a laissé ouvert il a
laissé rentrer des casseurs qu'on
connaît qui sonne vous pouvez pas dire
qu'il a je le joue assume c'est sûr
l'assument il a laissé rentrer les
casseurs est ce que vous pouvez dire ça
j'ai décidé de dire ça je l'assument
il a laissé rentrer les casseurs et j'ai
des amis qui étaient normalement je ne
fais donc tout à fait zélande les jaunes
ont lâchement cetera pendant ici on peut
finir est-ce qu'on avait hier lire ci
après vous ferez ce que voulait il a
laissé des rentrées les gens j'ai des
amis qui étaient qui tapait sur des
gilets jaunes inoffensif assis par terre
vous aviez tout eu des dingues qui
cassait qui le connaît truc les pavés
les crs regarder comme ça il ya même un
crs qui a dit à quelqu'un ça nous met en
rage de voir ça je peux vous dire qu'à
une manipulation d'état incroyable avec
le grand cinéma de castanet à la télé
des ultra droite
d'ailleurs quand on a arrêté les gens
s'est aperçu qu'ils étaient plutôt
d'extrême gauche et d'extreme droite
d'ambérieu cavendish dracula ya bien
quelques extraits mais pendant ce temps
là moi je peux vous dire j'étais à arles
la veille j'étais vous croyez qu'à
minuit sur une barrière de péage
une retraitée de 65 ans eu un cadre un
ouvrier
une auxiliaire de vie sont là à minuit
dans le froid et la pluie par plaisir
bonsoir que ce sont des cas la tendance
est restée parce que
et puis ça a été fait pour
décrédibiliser un mouvement nantis pour
la première fois violent est totalement
non adhérents sied polir ans ya deux
tons noir condamner les violences
messieurs du gagnant parce que c'était
la grande manif
c'était gelé condamné la violence des
barrières de péage en 2012 et on sait
fut à ces foutus de ma gueule
alors monsieur dupont-aignan juste show
est en train de souffrir je veux dire
vous êtes en train de dire une maison
sert à hollywood sur hollywood
vous paierez mise en scène pour dire si
ces gens qui sont ce les barrages et le
exemple nous parler monsieur
dupont-aignan vous inspirent les voilà
donc je voulais vous dire donc là si on
part de votre option par devaux grossir
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui disent
que vous êtes fait de la récupération et
qu'elle a pu faire sur le dos des gilets
jaunes est le cas alors vous et à vous
signifier aussi on vous écoute
si on vous dit non tout ça est fait
exprès et mise en scène par le
gouvernement bien sûr et donc pour tout
ça pour décrédibiliser un
surenchérissement des six nations
ces jeunes moi je vous l'assuré passé
s'empoignant je suis navré je l'assumé
c'est des mecs j'ai vu un ballon et
honda s'agit de preuves mais vous
raconter n'importe quoi
hammami assurant que vous avez pas vous
à le gouvernement c'est parce que vous
vous parce que c'est un mouvement sur le
mondial que vous manipulez pas que tout
le monde ait une c'est donc ce serait
les gens qu'ils soient liés dans le
monde et par moments ce nom n'a d'abord
j'ai la passion tout le monde est plein
d'envié tout le monde et à bago après
vous ma chérie le monde est perdant
le gouvernement aussi s'est
décrédibilisé en ne pouvant pas
organiser une manifestation qu'il s'agit
pas dire que le gouvernement en a
profité moi je m'oppose à la politique
du gouvernement
par contre je peux pas vous laisser dire
que c'est une manie comme ça le grand
complot c'est ça le premier est le
premier la grâce de la bigorre ils ont
été classés l'asie la concorde
la dernière fois qu'il ya une
manifestation on laisser parler les
dernières fois car dans une gestation
autorisé place de la concorde
c'est une date sanglant des jeux de
l'art est libre c'est le 6 février 1934
et les manifestations délire et elle
fait à côté de l'assemblée celle à côté
de la scène ces petits tracas pas pour
autoriser n'organisait pas beaucoup de
manifestations ça se voit pas ce qu'on
fait pas de manifestations à côté des
fleuves et parce que ces dons et alors
j'ai déjà
ça votre discours ni décrédibiliser les
policiers mais nous décrédibiliser les
institutions n'ont pas se [ __ ] une
conclusion on peut soutenir la gueule de
castaner parce qu'ils méritent
on doit contester cette politique parce
qu'elle est injuste mais vous pouvez pas
balancer comme ça du coup ne pouvez pas
dire ça ou de la manif et ça suffit on
voit des journalistes de plusieurs
chaînes d'info comme bfm et si news qui
sont pris à partie aussi tendance est en
stagnation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on voit ça alors les pourquoi
pourquoi je sais
est-ce que vous n'en voulez ou au
journaliste maxime alors on va être
dites nous la vérité on va écrire les
journalistes essayent tant bien que mal
de faire leur travail
d'accord leur direction pour des raisons
que j'ignore puisque je ne suis pas
journaliste mais j'ai les preuves que
j'ai puisque didier deschamps
enregistrements téléphoniques par
exemple de sienne ou de tf1 que
j'apprécie tout à l'heure d'avoir un
raccourci 15 minutes de discussion à
quatre secondes sans que je puisse rien
dire
à lévis voilà essaye de faire leur
travail comme ils peuvent
donc moi par exemple j'ai eu une
personne dans ma ville d ouest france à
qui j'ai dit quand vous faites votre
travail
essayez de le faire le plus clairement
possible sinon je ne peux pas vous
garantir que les gens en colère ne vous
prennent pas à partie sur les lieux de
manifestations évoquant des jeunes au
genou en quoi accepte pas ça je
n'accepte pas ça et donc la vie rien
juste pas combien de gens qui voient
mais il ne faut absolument pas s'en
prendre aux journalistes puisque
quoiqu'il arrive les gens ne sont pas
bêtes et on sait très bien quels médias
relatent la vérité et quels médias
essayent de la cacher et d'un lorsque
sur l'échangé s'est joué là dessus je
fais maxime et je suis média quel média
raulhac la vérité quel média monde m'a
dit tu nous fais pas je sais qu'ils sont
en train de dire qu'il ya des
porte-parole des gilets jaunes ou des
leaders voilà représentants
c'est faux ces assurances sont leurs
jeunes dire une connerie oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis justement hier soir dans
l'urgence dans l'urgence sans
concertation nationale donc les gens me
dit qui a voté pour une personne n'a
voté pour moi d'accord d'accord je suis
ni chef ni responsable ni dirigeants et
je n'ai rien à dire à personne
la seule raison pour laquelle dans
l'urgence hier soir huit personnes ont
été nommées porte parole c'est pour que
la voix du peuple soit écouter les
peuples veut quoi avoir son mot à dire
chaque personne dans ce pays veut avoir
son mot à dire s'il ya une nomination
c'est pourquoi c'est pour éviter par
exemple que monsieur dupont-aignan
distribuer des tracts j'ai rien personne
est contre vous mais on est apolitique
c'est pour dire le titien il faudra
acceptons sans problème et s'en va venir
que d'un lac dans une manifestation
décédé alors il a distribué des tracts
mais c'est juste parce qu'il fait une
soirée jeux vous êtes exact vous êtes le
bienvenu en tant que citoyen ce que nous
n'avons rien mais citoyen on n'a jamais
distribué un tract dans les
manifestations gilet jaune pour une
raison très simple c'est dans les gilet
jaune ya toutes les opinions pas ce
qu'on dit on va laisser la réalité sont
à prendre sur cinq dans les gg de cette
journée nous on veut plus de la
politique c'est ça que je vais dire à
mes gars de huit personnes et dire
qu'ils vont aller à l'elysée en passant
ça en boucle toute la journée alors que
le riz c'est faux et le un bain le
principal intéressé vous dit que c'est
faux maxime
cela dit c'est une première question
donc à par lui représentant c'est une
connerie il ya huit personnes qui sont
prévus pour amener ce que les gens
veulent d'abord une délégation à
l'elysée par exemple à l'elysée écoutez
c'est ce qu'on voudra ce que tout le
monde moi je suis pas d'accord avec lui
mais la seule alors lui donnons lui mais
parce que c'est difficile de se
comprendre quand il ya des mots qui sont
pas 10 comme il faut ça anormal toi tu
voudrais avoir ton moyens bien sûr donc
tu voudrais qui est international oui
d'abord donc sur 60e la légitimité de
macrez exactement s'il a plus de 50%
pour parler aux deux peuples
là vous remettons pas en cause les
institutions oui bah oui mais dans ces
révolutions on est dans cette révolution
de magnifiques mais alors on allait au
ni leoni qu'est la léonie qui les jaunes
en région parmi les fixes alors que
c'est pas léonie chasse et kahina fait
rien
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai dit ces prêts dont elle est
contente alors j'essaye d'abord
l'appareil
tu vas pas nous faire comme le petit
temps déjà nous on est on est contre la
destitution du président un parce que
nous on est venu à moi j'ai manifesté je
suis venu en bas de canal j value
magnifique seb le gilet jaune vaut bien
et tu veux quoi que allah alors
actuellement le souci ça vient pas du
président parce que ce que ce soit
monsieur du poignant ou bien madame
marie le pen
les problèmes sont les mêmes d'accord
alors il n'y a pas assez par un nouveau
représentant qui va changer quelque
chose qui va nous aujourd'hui ce qu'on
veut c'est qu'on a eu on a un grand
nombre de taxes alors je suis en halte à
la en alternance donc je touche 900
euros 900 euros je dois payer un loyer
900 euros je dois m'habiller 900 euros
je dois payer mes transports 900 euros
je dois paie l'électricité 900 euros je
dois payer la taxe d'habitation que
jeune recevoir alors je fais comment
maintenant mais je me dis alors qu'elle
n'a pas ce que toi je vois tu étais toi
tu es tu un peu comme nous en fait t'es
une gilet jaune qui veut que les choses
avancent est en vie juste d'être un beau
mais tu veux pas être dans la révolution
c'est ça voilà à l'heure mais je pense
que ça ça ça passe par quoi parce que ma
piscine parce que ça passe par quoi ça
passe par des manifestations on se
montre on montre qu'on est présent alors
aujourd'hui ce qu'on demande au
président c'est de baisser le nombre de
taxes comment font les autres pays qui
ont moins de taxes est bas alors vont
chercher ayari cinoche je suis fier il a
en allemagne et a dit un truc de
politique en place tu as dit que mine de
rien et je vais je vais le dire à
monsieur dupont-aignan qui est là il
faut arrêter les 80% des lois qui sont
actuellement en place c'est pas emmanuel
macron grillades à excuser la nina oui
mais attendez à un moment quand même
regarder les faits qui est ce qu a
augmenté les taxes sur l'essence ou le
diesel sur le fuel et sk
chaque ses 6 10 euros à sa barre des 10
euros attendus mais on a eu aujourd'hui
la réplique en marche à l'arrière joseph
halos andrew de taxi démocratie il ya 10
euros attendez au début c'est nous des
bus est né de quoi qu'à une vie euros
par référendum pour un plein de 45
litres
bâle a plein de 45,8 il ya eu 10 euros
supplémentaires depuis 2015
jusqu'en 2010 avec et il va y avoir 10
euros de plus à partir du 1er janvier et
1 parce qu'il nous a laissé et nord il
l'enlève n'ont hélas pas nous allons
monsieur non c'est énorme et je n'ai oui
mais l'eau des bus est née de sa famille
fondation de le problème c'est qu'on se
sont pas livrés pollueurs qui fait les
vrais pollueurs ne paye pas s'il vous
plaît pas tous en même temps ma chérie
problème guy nadon comme beaucoup le
problème de fond c'est l'injustice des
prélèvements se sont pas game bauer qui
paye
ce sont les gens s'y prennent leur
voiture dacia les convives sur le rsa
tour de table de la sur la justice le
géant du mandat qui récompense à tour de
table sur place et marron cannoise
est-ce que vous avez été crédibiliser
décrédibiliser le 24 novembre
ou est ce que vous sentez plus fort
maxime un mois je pense qu'on est plus
fort que jamais parce que il ya plein de
gens me nohra joundi ya des français qui
ont été choquées et concision c'est le
peuple qui ça va oui le peuple a par
définition un bout de table
j'aimerais avoir votre avis juste votre
avis là-dessus parce qu'on est très
précis laurence nord je pense pas je
pense que le mouvement il est tellement
profonde tellement puissant que sont pas
ces images de casseurs qui peuvent le
ternir en revanche vraiment je tiens à
saluer le travail des journalistes comme
jambes et font la file peironet gevrey
jean macé news venant toutes les autres
chaînes et qui sont là pour vous donner
la parole on vous a donné la parole
depuis le début de ce mouvement
ça fait trois semaines que vous êtes
sont tous nos plats tout donc par pitié
de nous agresser pas c'est ce que je
vous ai déjà le rappelle pas et je
répète là je n'appelle pas l'agression
des journalistes ça c'est important que
je demande
est-ce que je pense que beaucoup de gens
demandent pas ce que je peux pas donner
la parole du peuple je suis pas un messi
fait partie des 8
non je fais pas partir je fais partie de
huit personnes qui seront chargées de
dire que tout le monde doit donner sa
parole alors là maxime n'a rien à voir
avec être un un leader ou un truc comme
silent team juste vous voulez rencontrer
le chef de l'état c'est ça j'aimerais
bien le chef de l'état par cette
délégation écoute que tout le monde veut
donner sa parole par un référendum
qu'est ce que vous attendez du discours
d' emmanuel macron de demain à ce que
c'est ça non mais on attend turin lui 1
ce qu'on veut c'est être reçus qu'ils
acceptent la fira d'or et d'un arrêté
mais peut pas que ces référendums maxime
ses impôts ne serait pas possible
maxime je peux dire franchement c'est
impossible tu sais que je t'aime
beaucoup au moins c'est dylan ou là il
pourrait faire un référendum sur ces
fameuses sur son élan merci plan de
taxes attendait mais fusion proposée aux
sondés tablent pas sur le produit
importé vous assure l'une propose il
admet c'est faux si c'est le sac
auditions pour qu'elle coûte ce qu'on
demande nous on demande une baisse
une ruine enlève des taxis les enlève
comme les autres l'ont fait les
autorités messieurs ne veut pas tout ça
puis baisse les impôts ils enlèvent des
taxes et ils innovent ils innovent pour
trouver de l'argent comme les autres
alors tu n'as mots parce que franchement
c'est trop facile d'appeler la baisse
dépasse je me suis battu l'encadrement
des loyers
je sais très bien que votre situation
allait difficile et je sais juste que
pour plein de gens les services publics
sont de plus en plus loin et de plus en
plus dégradées et d'ailleurs on n'a pas
parlé pendant sept semaines de la
manifestation d infirmer des infirmières
qui font un boulot incroyable
mélissa vous pouvez pas dire nos taxes
parce que le consentement à l'impôt
l'impôt ce important et central un mot
c'est bien la centrale mais ce
consentement à l'impôt sesia l'ensemble
c'est ce qui fait que le problème le
problème le problème c'est la réaction
vous et moi sont moins de riches on paye
surtout pas là mais c'est quand même
vous arrêter vous arrêter ou les
arrêtent et où on paye des impôts et il
ya de plus en plus de gens qui échappent
à l'impôt un exemple un starbucks établi
en france depuis 2001 qui arrange tous
les cafés etc n'a pas payé un centime
d'impôt jeux puis ça peut bien qu'un
choix alors ils font des bénéfices
alors la solution lutter contre
l'évasion fiscale aurait conclu au mieux
répartir l'effort est engagé cette
transition énergétique parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on s'en sortira qu'est ce
que vous faites
alors vous êtes pour les taxes sur les
carburants et l'hommage de suivre la
transition et vous êtes pour les taxes
que l'un d'eux français vous aussi
voulez c'est la norme monsieur dupont
aignan 2 secondes devant la transition
je sais qu'on arrête de faire des débats
qui tourne autour de questions qui ne
seront jamais donc sur décret du
président demain il dit va te dois dire
quoi bas il doit simplement dire ok je
vous reçois vous voulez quoi
voilà ma très madame parce qu'on est en
démocratie c'est le peuple qui décide
les gens donnent laurent
regarde les extrêmes et je l'aide
accordée à chaque élection on va
jusqu'au tueur et j'aimerais juste faire
un dernier truc super oui maladie c'est
louis malle décide il a décidé le pape
il a voté dans 18 6% de la population
qui a voté vous service de navettes je
veux dire un truc je veux dire à toi moi
ces scènes ces débats qui ont peut pas
faire un référendum dès que 300000
personnes demande en référé au clan des
celi en français s'il vous plaît
on se calme mademoiselle depuis comment
vous appelez les oignons et je suis
actuellement au chômage
qu'est ce que vous attendez demain moi
j'attends pas de référendum et j'attends
juste que monsieur le président d'img
vouloir nous répondre voilà ne serait-ce
qu'une simple petite réponse à l'heure
actuelle français en vidant un on est
revenu au temps des rois c'est à dire
que en haut ça commence sa festoient etc
pendant que nous le petit peuple d'en
bas on commence à manger les restes au
bout d'un moment va falloir qu'il se met
à égalité à notre on est bien d'accord
que notre devise c'est égalité
fraternité et libertés à l'heure
actuelle on a plus de liberté
d'expression on se fait censurer presque
sur tous les médias à cause d'eux des
gilets jaunes
au bout d'un moment la liberté
d'expression elle est plus là alors
juste léonie léonie j'ai entendu votre
appel
voilà vous voulez que le chef de l'état
vous reçoivent et vous écoute juste
nicolas dupont aignan avant qu'on se
quitte à la fois vous étiez venu on
avait fait ça rappelez vous on avait
fait ça j'aurais qu'on fasse une petite
interview race raoult dark ages vous
montre des candidats vont me dit si pour
vous il saura sera au barca dans la vie
regardez attention jean luc mélenchon
dans la plus tôt n'ait d'arcade accord
très bien mais ça arrange toi et moi
même raoult d'arc à emmanuel macron
brassera parce qu'il est très faux cul à
d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
asra doha sera voilà du poignant je vous
mets une photo si je vous dis si je vous
mets marine le pen aujourd'hui dar kaoua
sera franchement je les ai soutenus face
à macro et j'ai bien eu raison parce
qu'on voit ce qu'on paye maintenant à la
baie des chaleurs est pas maintenant je
sur est indépendant de crasse marni
d'affermir à sera leader caennais année
dans l est encore à sera non ouais rien
dire attendez je change pas d'avis moi
je vous dis je suis pas je ne change pas
d'avis mais accord tout ce qu'on dit
marine le pen brassera ils ont voté pour
macron ils ont été manipulés vous grâce
à la casse rory juste dont il est chez
lui des traces ya plein de français au
cyril hanouna
j'ai été candidat au premier tour pour
éviter le choix entre mc roundup mais
bon après j'ai choisi les mariages et
une fois je choisis un moment et ils ont
tous et cyril hanouna
oui ils ont tous appelé à voter macron
[Rires]
encore la liberté de choisir son volant
mais c'est sûr mais mais bon on
attendait maxime maxi sur en deux
secondes
j'hésite sur les politiciens
comment voulez vous montrez pas les
politiciens laprise dérangeant la
politique mais juste mis à différents
nous allons parler après les chérir et
pat 1h22 ya john f
allez merci mes chéris